alors pour le moment la seule réaction
officielle proprement dites que j'ai vu
et quelque chose qui je pense à très
bientôt capturé l'humeur nationale en
Ukraine c'est le ministère de la Défense
qui est tout simplement lancé un tweet
avec les mots en anglais oui à watching
c'est certainement le cas l'Ukraine
regarde avec un très grand intérêt ce
qui se passe en Russie et non sont
humour en fait il y a beaucoup de même
et de blagues qui ont émergées mais
aussi beaucoup de spéculations je pense
que généralement la tendance est à
penser que quoi qu'il en soit c'est
quelque chose de positif pour l'Ukraine
qu'il y ait des divisions en Russie
c'est quelque chose qui affaiblit
Poutine quel que soit l'issue de ce
conflit qui est émergé entre Prigogine
et le ministère de la Défense et puis
maintenant visiblement entre le FSP
aussi puisque le FSP a ouvert une
enquête contre yef Kenny Prigogine
beaucoup semblent penser que cela ne va
pas durer très longtemps que priscogyne
sera bientôt tué d'autres pensent en
revanche que il a en fait de bonnes
chances de recruter des soldats parmi
les forces armées de la Russie puisque
ces derniers doivent être sensibles à
son discours il doit être forcément
insatisfaits de ce qui se passe comment
ils sont traités ils doivent être rendus
compte pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux que les raisons avancées pour cette
invasion était clairement fausse que
l'Ukraine ne s'apprêtait pas à attaquer
la Russie ou même juste la partie
occupée du tonne basse comme il l'a dit
clairement hier alors il y a des
différences d'opinions et beaucoup
beaucoup de discussions en ligne je
pense que c'est intéressant aussi de
regarder la réaction chez ces deux
groupes de paramilitaires russes qui
combattent aux côtés de l'Ukraine en
Ukraine et aussi plus récemment en
Russie dans la région de Belgrade qui
ont fait ces incursions ils ont des
réactions très différentes le corps des
volontaires russes qui est plus associée
avec des néonazis tout comme en partie
Wagner aussi comme son nom l'indique
n'est pas allé jusqu'à saluer l'action
mais à tout de même
issu une déclaration ils ont dit qu'ils
estiment qu'il est un vrai patriote de
la Russie et il y avait une certaine
admiration je pense pour sa démarche
l'autre groupe de paramilitaires russes
anti Poutine c'est la Légion de la
Russie libre eux ils ont eu un discours
très différent où ils ont dit on ne doit
absolument pas perdre de vue ce que il
Prigogine a fait contre ses propres
soldats
l'extraordinaire violence les tortures
qu'il a employées ce n'est en aucun cas
quelqu'un en qui on peut placer une
quelconque espoir on attend de voir
évidemment comment ça va évoluer
Gulliver Craig autre question sur les
explosions entendues à l'aube
à Kiev qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire
alors malheureusement il y a deux morts
c'est quand des fragments
je ne sais pas en fait si c'était un
drone ou une requête excusez-moi qui a
été explosé par un missile solaire
ukrainien des fragments ont touché les
étages supérieurs d'un immeuble
d'appartement détruisant quelques
appartements et faisons un plusieurs
blessés en plus de ces deux personnes
qui ont été tuées sinon il y a eu une
vingtaine de drones et de requêtes qui
ont été abattues mais les l'Armée de
l'Air n'a pas encore publié à sa
déclaration pour donner le chiffre exact
ce n'est pas uniquement Kiev qui a été
frappé et ses frappes qui ont eu lieu au
plaisir vagues pendant la nuit il y a eu
plusieurs fois la sirène retentit donc
on a vraiment passé une nuit sans
sommeil c'est pas uniquement Kiev c'est
aussi ni prosa pourrija admis pro il y a
des blessés à zapporisa c'était des
missiles
S300 sol mais je n'ai pas encore
formations sur d'éventuelles dégâts ou
victimes l'univers krague correspondant
en France 24 en Ukraine merci